emmanuel macron smiling like a man who
thinks he's won
he is well ahead in the opinion polls
this event felt as much like a
celebration as a rally
but the president is still pressing his
message that the election is about
protecting france's core values
the 24th of april will be a referendum
for or against a republic that is
secular united indivisible and those are
the things we support
he even smiled his way through a small
protest saying this was a sign of a
healthy democracy
democracy
congratulate yourself for being in a
democracy where you can harangue a
president and a candidate like this
i hope this can continue to be on the
24th of april because with another
candidate it would have been different
[Applause]
this has been a divisive campaign has
always been the front runner but he's
still not widely adored in france too
many people thinking
and elitist
his speech culminating in the national
anthem they may not love him but he does
put on a show and grudging admiration
can take you a long way in french
politics
[Music]
[Applause]
between the plague and cholera it's
difficult
i think marine le pen is worse but with
macron it's not going to be easy
we've traveled with the president this
week as he's gone from city to
countryside shoring up support
this was him in sandini north of paris
it's an area of deprivation and social
problems two weeks ago these people
voted for the socialist genre melanchon
in the first round but now many came out
for macron
i think that
he will be a great president if he wins
if he wins a
decent day i was very satisfied for
his five years of work and now i want
him for five more years
it's 20 years since the president last
won re-election and back then the loser
was marine le pen's father jean-marie
but this is a different era a different
president and a different le pen
the opinion polls say macron will win
easily but remember opinion polls can be
wrong
adam parsons sky news paris